je t'ai pas encore tout expliqué mais
dans mon dossier il y a Morgane on a
pris le genre d'une agence en otage et
le pauvre monsieur pendant plusieurs
heures on est resté chez lui
la torturer et le faire parler ou le
coffre et ceci cela on l'a frappé on a
assez horrible et je ne réalisais pas ce
que je faisais à ce moment-là mais c'est
une fois emprison après plusieurs mois
que je me réveillais tous les matins en
me disant qu'est-ce que je fais ici
[Musique]
je m'appelle Thierry Marx je suis un
chef étoilé
dans mon restaurant DIGNE LES GRANDES
semences
mais je n'ai pas toujours connu les
palaces j'ai grandi dans une cité
aménilmontant dans le Paris populu des
années 70
j'aurais pu mal tourner mais la vie m'a
offert une deuxième chance je n'ai
jamais oublié
depuis des années je donne des cours de
cuisine à des détenus pas pour qu'ils
deviennent de grands chefs mais pour
qu'ils aient un projet après dehors
en France nos prisons sont mal en point
et il est pratiquement impossible d'y
entrer une caméra
j'ai envie d'aller voir ce que font nos
voisins je veux savoir comment ailleurs
on enferme les prisonniers et comment on
les prépare à la liberté
pour le découvrir
je vais réunir directeur et détenu
autour d'une même table le temps d'un
dîner
[Musique]
je me lance dans un tour de robe des
prisons destination la Belgique
[Musique]
la prison d'Andenne ouvre ses portes
sauf qu'en Belgique il est possible de
filmer un visage découvert les détenus
qui le souhaitent et le directeur de
prison parle librement ça change tout
avant de commencer je fais un crochet
par les cuisines
[Musique]
bonjour
bonjour bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
j'ai trois jours pour organiser un repas
avec les détenus
c'est de là je trouve pas bien du tout
est-ce là pour que vraiment le chauffeur
il faut la mettre sur 6 aussi direct à
fond ok casserole poils
chinois c'est là grosse casserole grosse
casserole ça c'est des ronds parmi tous
ceux que j'ai rencontrés 5 participants
au dîner ce repas nous allons préparer
ensemble
quand on partage les mêmes plats on
finit toujours partie dire les choses
donc un gros mixeur
Andenne est une prison wallonne à une
heure de route au sud-est de Bruxelles
cette maison de peine comme on dit en
Belgique a été inauguré en 1997
c'est une prison de haute sécurité
407 détenus que des hommes surtout des
longues peines
après des années de surpopulation
aujourd'hui la plupart des condamnés
vivent en cellules individuelle
la prison très difficile au début je
n'accepte pas l'enfermement j'ai peur je
suis dans un milieu que je ne connais
pas il y a pas papa et maman où mon
grand frère pour me défendre je suis
tout seul
après cinq jours j'étais déjà en train
de me bagarrer dans le préau parce qu'il
y a un mec qui avait l'impression que je
dois regarder de travers
ici c'est mon espace de vie journalier
ça c'est mon lit c'est pas trop beau d'y
rester couché trop souvent parce que
c'est une salle habitude
où tu prends tes tartines et ton thermos
et tu vas travailler ou alors tu prends
la voix illégale mais il faut là il faut
aller à fond il faut y aller à fond
on est des humains à la base on n'est
pas des animaux oui on a fait des
bêtises on a un temps de prison mais il
faut laisser cette chance
[Musique]
j'arrive sur le coup de midi ici pas de
réfectoire
et là vous les là vous desservez les
cellules
les repas sont distribués par des
servants des détenus volontaires
c'est quoi ces poissons c'est du poulet
poulet
végétarien
ils sont un peu moins mais c'est à peu
près ça
et c'est pour les régimes tout ça
il y a trois régimes alimentaires
l'ordinaire le musulman et le végétarien
depuis plus de 20 ans l'administration
belge n'a pas augmenté le budget
nourriture
3,30 € par prisonnier et par jour ici
aussi les caisses de l'État sont vides
y venez au Congo il est arrivé en
Belgique à 3 ans à 15 ans il décroche de
l'école à 19 ans il participe à un
braquage qui tourne mal pour lui c'est
les assises il prend 25 ans
pour 5 ou 20% des Français touchent une
corde de
toutes ces années moi j'ai vraiment fait
en sorte de toujours appeler ma mère
tous les soirs même si c'est pour 5
minutes comment tu vas juste ça
j'entends ça va je vais bien c'est bon
et elle aussi elle en tant que je vais
bien voilà parce que ils ne savent pas
comment ça se passe pour nous ici il se
demande est-ce qu'il mange bien est-ce
qu'il dort ce qu'il a pas trop de souci
et puis quand ils viennent à la visite
qu'il voit et que on a peut-être un peu
maigri ou quand c'est chamaya qu'un
autre détenu qu'on a un coup bleu ou
quoi visiter automatiquement ça va pas
il a des problèmes et
ceux qui s'en sortent bien c'est ceux
qui ont un groupe derrière
une bande sont en groupe ils achètent
ils trafic ils font tout là il y a pas
de problème mais le gars qui est tout
seul isolé qui arrive qui veut acheter
qui veut se montrer qu'il a un peu
d'argent c'est voilà il se fait bouffer
j'en ai vu
ils sont convertis juste pour ne pas se
faire casser la gueule ils sont
convertis à une religion
voilà et c'est qui ces gens-là c'est pas
moi qui va venir inquiéter une venir
dire écoute tu me donnes une enveloppe
si tu veux sortir au préau ça va pas non
c'est plutôt réservé pour un belge pour
un blanc c'est malheureux mais c'est
comme ça et dire qu'ils sont chez eux
dans un univers aussi macho cette
sincérité est rare surtout venant d'un
colosse d'un mètre 94 j'ai trouvé mon
premier invité
je passe dans les LC réserver aux
détenus difficiles
cellule 21 à 25 je vais rencontrer un
blanc un Belge que personne ne raquette
Jean-Paul c'est le roi du Braquo et de
l'évasion
aujourd'hui
les Kings de Belgique
[Musique]
aller voir nous
c'est pour donner de l'humidité en fait
dans la cellule
je mets une casserole et je mets de
l'eau dedans et alors j'allume parce que
des fois il y a pas radiateur qui va
donc il fait très froid dans la cellule
ça réchauffe la cellule et en même temps
ça en mettant de l'eau dans la casserole
ça humidifie l'air
avec mes longues années de prison je
sais pas pourquoi je me suis mis ça dans
la tête un jour mais il y a je veux pas
dire combien de temps j'estime qu'à
partir de 5 heures du soir surtout
l'hiver la journée est finie pour moi
17h la journée est finie parce que déjà
il y a plus rien qui marche pas de
comptabilité pas directement
pas de pas de greffe pas de travailleur
donc les chefs donc jusqu'à donner les
téléphones et les douches au détenu donc
voilà moi à partir de 5 euros en hiver
donc je me le sais appliqué aussi pour
l'été donc quand il est 5 heures du soir
pour moi la journée est finie
si on s'évade proprement on faisait un
trou dans le mur aussi on les barreaux
moi je suis un évader comme ça mon frère
moi je suis une belette quoi j'ai une
belette si je veux un emplacement de
travail c'est au vu de m'évader quoi
dans mon dans mon optique dit à 4h30 ça
quoi à peu près parce que là je me suis
vachement calmé quoi mais moi
mais moi je suis très très fier de moi
comme je me suis reprise j'ai reconnu
des hold-ups pendant parce qu'il fallait
vivre se cacher manger louer des boxes
acheter des armes et puis tout ça ben
quand on vous arrête on vous recommande
pour tout ça pousser sur une arme de
guerre tout autant hold-up out un vol de
voiture et alors il cumule tout ça il
vous faut un paquet et je suis remonté
mes deux évasions à 29 ans en plus quoi
en tout quoi en tout cas en plus
[Musique]
j'ai connu peu de détenus comme
Jean-Paul à 47 ans il a passé toute sa
vie d'adulte en prison
il sera mon deuxième invité
je suis arrivé il y a quelques heures à
peine mais visiblement l'info est passée
j'entre dans la section 3B il est 19h
pendant les activités les détenus au
Quartier Libre les étages sont fermés
mais les cellules restent ouvertes
pendant une heure 45
ce qui ne veulent pas du buffet froid
offert par la maison peuvent préparer
l'ordinaire à l'étage ils achètent les
produits à l'épicerie de la prison
je viens voir la célébrité de la section
le roi du poulet mafé
c'est chez moi ici pour l'instant quoi
les années
j'espère que ça va pas trop durer
je suis là
aubergine carotte
si je ne trouve pas les champignons
[Musique]
c'est moi c'est moi je suis occupé là
ouais tantôt ça va
ouais ouais je t'appelle tantôt
téléphone
[Musique]
même si tu veux pas compter ils sont à
voter ou les a dit oui la cuisine il est
passé à la cuisine
la liberté a pas de prix
c'est des tensions
attraper une maturité que j'avais pas de
haut
comme je réfléchis aujourd'hui
il y a deux ans ces jours et la nuit
et voilà
comme je vous ai dit là tantôt soit de
la prison soit ça vous remplit des piles
soit parce que les plus intelligents
plus matures et moi heureusement c'est
dans le bon sens
un projet fait tenir cet homme le
restaurant africain qui rêve d'ouvrir à
sa sortie
ça sent bon c'est super bon
je détenu va me donner un bon coup de
main en cuisine
[Applaudissements]
ma première journée est terminée j'ai
trois invités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
en prison comment cuisine les choses
sérieuses commencent tôt
les cellules sont restées fermées toute
la nuit personne ne sait ce qu'ici est
passé
la première réunion de la journée est
très importante les surveillants
échangent sur les détenus les plus
difficiles
vigilance avec notre ami à
à partir
c'est bien passé hier
c'est le meeting du matin
ce qui s'est passé
en même temps elle en est venu ce qui a
des enfants on sait pas si on va
retourner nickel quoi en fait c'est ça
le boulot moi je pense pour moi
maintenant je suis pas mes collègues moi
je suis perdu
on est magnifique
il m'a confié qu'il avait reçu des
menaces de mort
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es malade tu as fait ton
sport hier
ça fait trop de sport hier
[Musique]
il maintient son nom j'ai pas commencé
sinon j'arrête pas toute la journée
dans la vie d'un surveillant l'ouverture
des portes est un moment redoutée chaque
matin
les détenus les plus fragiles se
laissent aller et ne sortent plus de
leurs cellules d'autres deviennent
agressifs ou tombent dans la folie
maintenant à force d'être là et de les
connaître et entamer un dialogue on sait
plus ou moins ce qui prennent et quand
ils apprennent quand ils ne prennent pas
on voit les réactions
[Musique]
il y a su que la prison a détruit et ce
que la prison a fait mûrir comme il
ah non ça n'a rien
du tout il y a pas de forme là
le programme c'est échauffement en
disant il est devenu un athlète et
surtout devenu un homme exactement tu
sais pourquoi tu es là tu t'es pas
encore dans le doute par rapport à ça et
on sent que c'est assumé quoi c'est
assumé donc ça te permet de conduire la
détention peut-être dans de meilleures
conditions ou pas
c'est à partir du moment où j'ai accepté
ma peine et que je l'assumais que ça
s'est bien passé pour moi j'ai commencé
à prendre du poids à faire du sport plus
me disputer avec les gens plus jouer un
rôle parce qu'à un moment donné je joue
un rôle je me je vivais en prison et je
me sentais un peu comme détenu je me
disais ma vie elle est ici voilà et ça
c'était pas bon c'était dangereux
j'avais complètement oublié ma famille
l'espoir de sortir un jour et tout ça et
je faisais n'importe quoi je t'ai pas
encore tout expliqué mais
on a pris le gérant d'une agence en
otage et le pauvre monsieur pendant
plusieurs heures on est resté chez lui
la torturer le faire parler ou le coffre
et ceci cela on l'a frappé on a assez
horribles et je ne réalisais pas ce que
je faisais à ce moment-là mais c'est une
fois emprison après plusieurs mois que
je me réveillais tous les matins en me
disant qu'est-ce que je fais ici pas
chez moi même la nuit des fois de me
réveiller pourquoi je suis là comme si
il y avait des moments
dès que j'ai réalisé ce que j'avais fait
que un homme était mort et tout ça
s'écrit me revenait
c'était horrible là j'ai eu un gros coup
de déprime
pourquoi construire après c'est quand
même
très difficile je comprends ça aussi à
la victime
[Musique]
je retrouve Jean-Paul lui aussi a grandi
à l'ombre
[Musique]
c'est un livre des records à lui tout
seul il a écumé toutes les prisons de
Wallonie plus de 200 cellules une vie
dans 9 mètres carrés
tu as pris du recul par rapport à tout
ça toi
par rapport à la détention
moi-même tu vois c'était moi-même il
fallait que sur moi se déclic quoi
un moment donné c'est malheureux d'avoir
attendu 27 ans mais moi avec
les orphelinats ciseaux tout de suite tu
vois moi je suis au niveau de
l'institution ce que je dis je suis
institutionnalisé moi
j'ai connu que ça dans ma vie quoi
mise à part ça avec ma mère
elle est battue depuis que je suis né
moi je ramasse des trois aussi mes
frères aussi donc ben voilà quoi ciseaux
elle nous prend tous les trois elle part
elle va chez une copine elle nous dépose
là elle dit bon bah je vais me bouger
les le plus vite possible et ça c'est
quand même 6 ans qui a été marié avec
mon père mais elle était battue quoi
elle voulait plus de tout ça et elle
nous a pris et elle a demandé le divorce
et là le juge fait la mauvaise décision
quoi il décide de nous placer quoi vers
12 ans je commence à fuguer tout le
temps j'ai une passe où je suis tout le
temps je retourne tout le temps chez ma
mère
et puis sur les vêtements
qu'il faut pas j'ai 14 ans et demi et le
soir même je vous retrouve dans une Golf
GTI volée
et ça allait toujours de plus en plus
haut quoi
ouais toujours plus quoi donc là on est
dans le braquage on est dans la salle on
est pas
c'est la belle vie vraiment ouais
et
je vais sur mes 18 ans et je dis à 18
ans j'arrête à 18 ans j'arrête parce que
si j'arrête pas 18 ans c'est foutu et je
sais pas m'arrêter à 18 ans
je vais pas en faire un enfant de cœur
et si le juge n'avait pas arraché
Jean-Paul à sa mère
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il aurait pris le
même chemin
le dîner approche
le directeur a accepté mon invitation et
mon équipe de cuisine est presque
constituée il est temps de faire le
marché ça change ça change oui
sera libre dans un an
en Belgique comme en France à quelques
mois de leur libération les fans ont le
droit de sortir seuls pour la journée
aujourd'hui Hicham va m'aider à faire
les courses et notre taxi c'est le
fourgon cellulaire
[Musique]
j'ai envie d'améliorer l'ordinaire de
mes invités quelques produits simples
qui ont du goût et qui n'entre jamais en
prison
[Musique]
c'est
une odeur c'est une odeur de rien
les Portobello ça très bon champignon
italien très bon
d'élevage donc ça a poussé sur
sur des toiles comme ça
c'est beau
ouais
s'il vous plaît
maintenant que les champignons n'ont
plus de secret pour Hicham je l'invite
au dîner de demain au menu des girolles
de l'anguille fumé un poulet fermier des
pommes et du potimarron
[Musique]
j'ai vu beaucoup de prison partout les
courses ressemblent
[Musique]
le monde des surveillants s'arrête ici
passer le tourniquet c'est le territoire
des détenus
Yves Weiss sur moi
[Musique]
on a l'impression que tout va bien
Andenne mais il ne faut pas se fier aux
apparences
une émeute très violente à paralyser
l'établissement en 2011 en cause les
prières collectives ici trois détenus
sur 4 sont de confessions musulmanes
faire des gens qui sont vraiment
musulmans qui font vraiment la prière
qui font leur 5 prières par jour qui se
lèvent qui vont du sport que une hygiène
de vie est en Inde bien sûr qui
radicalisent les gens qui les
convertissent et qui leur mettent un
petit peu des idéologies
et l'administration a voulu interdire au
mecs de prier ensemble et ça ça a été
voilà quoi l'étincelle ils ont mis le
feu
et ils ont affiché une note et il
fallait pas du coup les mecs ils n'ont
pas voulu réintégrer leur cellules ça a
été la guerre tout était cassé les
agents n'ont pas pu revenir ils sont
partis en courant évidemment
heureusement pour eux il y a pas eu de
blesser grave et de mort mais
voilà la police a dû venir et puis force
un petit peu les mecs avant la
réintégrer leur cellules et les meneurs
ont été conduits au cachot et puis
transféré quoi
[Musique]
je reviens dans le monde des
surveillants
j'observe Alain le chef du PC sécurité
de son siège il contrôle toute la prison
mais dans sa forteresse il est parfois
bien seul
surtout quand ça dérape la dernière
prise d'otage en 2013 la bien secoué
je ne me vois pas moi ou comment d'un
centre comme ça
ne pas ouvrir pour empêcher le détenu de
s'évader alors que je vois mon collègue
enfin ma collègue avec la main là le
sang qui coule puis bon si jamais un
moment donné lâche et puis que voilà moi
je me sens responsable de la vie de ma
collègue donc on ferait un au maximum
oui mais on laisse partir et voilà on
ralenti au ralenti au ralenti et puis
quand ils sont arrivés dehors ben la
collègue qui saigne aux mains ils l'ont
laissé là ils ont parti avec la deuxième
collègue et on les a retrouvé je ne sais
combien de kilomètres plus loin ils ont
ils ont fait des accidents tout ils ont
essayé de mettre le feu à la première
voiture il essaie la collègue dedans la
voiture qu'ils essayent de mettre le feu
heureusement que la police est
intervenue assez rapidement qu'ils l'ont
sorti mais autrement comment c'est le
sens que sortir
mais ça c'est facile déjà quelques
années mais j'y pense toujours
on n'est pas payé pour ça
mais il y a une vraie solidarité entre
vous agent de la pénitentielle
quand il se passe quelque chose avec un
agent de quelques brigades ce soir tout
le monde a derrière lui on essaie
d'avoir le
soutien de tout le monde mais
au début on vient vers vous mais après
on ose plus venir
parce que justement ils savent que vous
intérieurement vous revivez ça et eux ne
veulent pas non plus revenir trop
souvent là-dessus pour ne pas tout le
temps remuer remuer les choses et mon
agression au couteau c'est quelque chose
que moi au départ je ne pensais jamais
en arriver à recevoir le coup de couteau
le couteau a tapé dans mon Bashung
si je n'ai pas mon bâtiment je suis pas
certain que je vous parle aujourd'hui
depuis Alan un peu plus travailler au
contact des prisonniers il est arrivé à
son siège dans son bocal
[Musique]
où tu vas où tu vas
bien
Rachid joue sa dernière partie demain il
retrouve la liberté
ça va vous êtes prêts
[Musique]
je suis parti
il a déjà purgé 4 ans derrière les
barreaux
sa dernière année il l'a fait avec un
bracelet électronique
bracelet qui a cassé en attendant qu'on
lui en pose un autre il a fait 10 jours
à Andenne
école bracelet à la Maison
du plastique
ultime étape avant la sortie Rachid
récupère ses effets personnels
ici
j'espère pour toi que c'est la dernière
fois que tu vas rester dans un sens
d'attente et qu'on se verra plus ici
un simple sac pas vraiment de projet
toutes les sorties se ressemblent
[Musique]
Marc didier est un directeur atypique
avec lui pas de langue de bois en 25 ans
de carrière il en a vu passer des
condamnés il a sa petite idée sur les
vertus de la prison
je pense que l'enfermement quel qu'en
soit la forme est une mauvaise chose je
ne pense pas que l'on puisse donner une
valeur pédagogique à une situation
d'enfermement d'un individu dans 9
mètres carrés parfois deux par fois 3
hommes ou femmes dans une même cellule
je ne pense pas que ce soit un milieu
propice à une quelconque amélioration
d'un quelconque comportement donc je
crois qu'un jour puisque la prison n'a
quand même pas toujours existé j'espère
qu'un jour en n'existera plus il faut
qu'on pense résolument à autre chose
on appelle ça inquisitoire je ne m'y
attendais pas de la part d'un directeur
de prison
le jour du dîner est arrivé mes invités
sont là
mais avant de passer à table il faut
cuisiner
[Musique]
potage de potimarron fricassée de
volaille aux girolles poêlée de pommes
caramélisées servis sur brioche nous
avons deux heures pour réaliser un repas
digne d'une grande table
ça c'est le tablier traditionnel des
cuisiniers alors ça c'est cadeau vous le
garderez ça vous fera un souvenir ferait
des dessins dessus vous cuisinerez dans
avec mais vous en avez un chacun donc on
prend comme ça
face à votre nombril
vous tournez ici
vous ressortez les deux cordons là
on tire et c'est gauche sur droite
et droite sur gauche d'accord
on va faire
crème de potimarron potimarron ça
ressemble à une petite citrouille en
fait goût un peu de marron tous les
légumes qu'on a sont bio donc très très
bon pour la santé donc on va essayer de
les cuire correctement pour pas perdre
la richesse de ce produit on va faire
une fricassée de volaille et on va
comprendre comment on a dans chaque
partie de la volaille des goûts un peu
différents
oui je sais ça vous rappelle une
émission
mais là on est en prison et les couteaux
de cuisine sont entre les mains des
détenus
j'ai l'habitude il faut garder l'oeil ne
jamais hausser le ton tant que
l'ambiance est sereine il n'y a pas de
problème
c'est que c'est trop répétitif la
nourriture en prison
lundi on sait qu'est-ce qu'on va manger
dimanche une question à manger mercredi
on te dit qu'on va manger c'est toujours
la même chose c'est ça le problème
quelqu'un a regardé l'heure non moins 20
qu'est-ce que c'est la cuisine
c'est quoi la cuisine c'est l'occupation
ça fait plaisir c'est un plaisir c'est
moi je dirais que c'est un poème
maîtrise du geste maîtrise du feu
maîtrise du temps
j'ai fait la connerie vous voyez j'ai
pas pris leur donc maintenant si le
client il arrive
c'est la
toujours garder l'heure les temps de
cuisson maîtrise de l'énergie
ouais quand ça
[Musique]
maîtrise du geste maîtrise du feu
maîtrise du temps
[Musique]
j'ai voulu dresser une jolie table
quelques bougies une nappe blanche on en
oublierait presque les barreaux
crème de potimarron c'est prêt les
toasts pour manger avec
l'anguille fumé c'est prêt
[Musique]
hier ils étaient seuls dans leur
cellules aujourd'hui ils forment une
équipe ma brigade marche à plein régime
doucement vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y se
fait avoir
super
[Musique]
ça m'étonne c'est un peu la rose des
champignons
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est des
champignons qui
coûtention il y avait au moins 10 sortes
de tomates j'ai jamais vu de ma vie des
tomates
et tu sais que les clients quand ils
vont au magasin ciseaux palais tomates
rondes pour eux c'est pas normal c'est
pas normal
de tous les modèles mais les gens ils
doivent leur conditionnement
c'est rouge
alors que les autres ont plus de goûts
plus de j'ai vu une pommade on dirait
des citrouilles
on a vu la même truc à mon avis
parce que je vois que ça saute
c'est le voisin
j'espère qu'il amène ma bouteille de vin
ouais c'est les invités qui arrivent
bonjour messieurs bonjour bonjour
le directeur d'Andenne à tout de suite
accepté mon invitation ça va bonjour
j'allais vous dire bienvenue mais je
suis pas dans mon restaurant
c'est très risqué il a joué le jeu
en principe les détenus ne croisent le
directeur qu'à leur arrivée ou en cas de
problème de discipline là ils vont être
à la même table pour nous tous c'est une
première
si vous me le permettez quand même un
petit conseil c'est d'aller sur l'onglet
c'est d'aller sur la fumée
[Musique]
ce sont des détenus qui frappent
vraiment
c'est bon c'est la première fois que
vous faisiez le marché avec un chef
des chefs
je pense qu'ils veulent
est-ce que c'est l'argent est-ce que
cela sibridité est-ce que s'il est cool
vous avez oublié le physique
j'aimerais le croire j'aimerais le
croire je me dis j'ai un physique de
Pitbull c'est vrai
non mais pitbull aussi
un meuble difficile à bouger la magie
opère
l'atmosphère se réchauffe le directeur
ouvre le bal
moi ce qui m'intéresse de savoir c'est
comment est-ce que vous vous ressentez
le fait d'être dans un établissement
dont on dit énormément de choses à ces
négatives à l'extérieur toutes les
prises de Belgique
détenus c'est ça ouais
une très bonne réputation avant mais ce
qui a fait que la réputation d'Andenne
s'est dégradée c'est le dernier
mouvement qui a eu les détenus en tout
cassé et puis tout le monde a été puni
et puis là on est privé d'activité mais
il y a eu aussi les prises otages ça je
pense que c'est impressionne beaucoup
plus les agents que les meufs
ils veulent pas garder des moutons ou
des chèvres ils viennent garder des
détenus et rebut de la Société des
crapules ils doivent s'attendre à ce qui
est déclages qui ait des bagarres sur
section ça arrive que des mecs
s'énervent ils sortent regardez les
mauvais humeur j'en ai connu pour sa
mandala je il s'énerve voilà il se met à
frapper des agents avec qui il a jamais
eu de problème c'est comme ça il y a des
crapules ici donc ils doivent s'attendre
à ce moment donné ça tourne mal non il y
en a beaucoup il y en
et vous vous avez connu la prison de
papa et la prison aujourd'hui il y a
quoi comme différence au début j'ai pas
accepté les femmes surveillance
est venu me trouver m'a dit monsieur je
suis votre cellule je dis oh tu te crois
toi je dis et tu crois que moi j'aurais
fait dans tes petites culottes moi je
dis tu veux que j'aille dans tes petites
culottes moi tu peux t'emmener qui tu
veux tu vas rien fouiller du tout c'est
pas bien je dis tu es complètement
frapper du bulle toi toi tu vas me dire
me dire à moi que tu vas venir fouiller
dans mes calebut et mon courrier et
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a changé alors
mais pas forcément dans votre situation
personnelle mais dans ce que vous vivez
dans un établissement comme celui-ci
avec le nombre d'années vous avez
derrière vous surtout ça qui a changé
c'est que moi la seule chose que j'ai
compris c'est qu'en 23 ans de prison
c'est pas l'endroit pour se faire des
amis c'est pas l'endroit pour se faire
des potes ni des copains
[Musique]
alors c'est de volaille avec l'ail
d'Arleux fumé c'est à peine chaud mais
manger promptement
et c'est une volaille fermière vous
allez voir le blanc et la cuisse c'est
deux goûts différents on a fait deux
cuissons différentes
puis il y a aussi un autre fléau
c'est la drogue on nous en parler tantôt
la drogue les médicaments voilà ici la
plupart des mecs j'envoie je me demande
comment est-ce qu'ils tiennent debout ça
leur donne un tas de médicaments assis
tous les matins dans les années 90 au
moment où on a osé parler de l'existence
de la circulation de la drogue dans les
établissements on voyait vraiment des
épaves humaines en prison on voyait des
types qui se tenaient au mur tellement
ils étaient chargés
il y avait pas besoin de faire un test
d'urine ou quoi que ce soit pour savoir
et à l'heure actuelle je peux imaginer
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de drogues
dans l'établissement mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'il y a une maîtrise de la
consommation qui est plus assumée on
voit plus des des zombies vraiment et
maintenant je constate que les jeunes
ils en veulent pas quoi ils ont
tellement vu le grand frère l'air copain
du quartier devenir des épaves que eux
au continu à grandir et il voyait qu'il
perdaient leurs dents qui faisait la
tente pour rien et moi je trouve que la
jeunesse de maintenant il y en a qui
vole le coup quand même quoi vraiment
surtout dans les stups quoi parce que
c'est un gros problème gros gros
problème c'est pas vrai c'est pire et ça
sera le pire en pire les gens ils ont
plus facile à prendre de la cocaïne
c'est devenu banal avant c'était pas
avant nous et même pas parler de cocaïne
maintenant les jeunes ils prennent tous
de la cocaïne c'est facile ouais je bois
un verre pour pour prendre de volant
mais t'inquiète je vais je vais tirer un
rail de cocaïne je serai je serai
d'aplomb ça va me réveiller quand on me
dit que maintenant les jeunes ils sont
ben non c'est pas vrai c'est pire nous
dans les quartiers dans les années 80
la drogue
on en voyait pas c'était fait pour les
intellectuels ou mais nous les poissons
riches nous on trafic on prenait quoi on
prenait des autoradios je voyais les
copains qui piquaient des mobylettes
enfin qui trafiquent un peu mais
effectivement moi quand je suis revenu
10 ou 15 ans après dans les quartiers on
a vu un business installé et comme il y
avait plus de travail pour les parents
un moment donné il y a un business qui
s'est installé autour de de la drogue et
là c'est devenu vraiment vraiment
incontrôlable
[Musique]
pour finir le repas en douceur un de mes
desserts préférés
voilà tu peux les servir tu peux me
confier avec une crème de spéculoos
c'est juste une théorie
[Musique]
gagner pendant deux heures des gens tout
opposent se sont parlés
[Musique]
je veux revoir Jean-Paul une dernière
fois dans sa cellule s'il se tient
carreau dans 30 mois il sera libre
je revis de
rouler dans la rosée du matin j'ai envie
de
m'accrocher un art j'ai envie de
j'ai envie de
j'ai envie d'aller nager dans la mer pas
trop loin mais
j'ai envie
de soleil j'ai envie de le soleil c'est
quelque chose qui manque c'est terrible
terrible terrible le soleil c'est la vie
ouais c'est la vie c'est
ce qui me manque le plus
c'est dans ces 9 mètres carrés
[Musique]
ici comment France la prison remplit mal
sa mission elle enferme mais elle ne
prépare pas à la près
tôt ou tard la plupart des prisonniers
font leur retour parmi nous
mais sans instruction
comment faire des hommes libres
[Musique]
j'ai passé
trois quatre jours
sympa
tout le temps en prison franchement
a fait du bien
à refaire